all right so we're finally here we Nova
can come down contain yourself can Nova
with PewDiePie limits on skin oh my god
this is why no one shows up fanfictions
what we we have today's challenge or
whatever we call I don't know why I keep
calling it a challenge but we are going
to create each other on OkCupid which is
a dating site and the challenge is that
whoever gets the most dick pics
what next money will win I wasn't
filming about this oh there's Nova stuff
I think he hung up oh no he's in now if
I if I send my own if I send my own does
that count as well sure yeah you can ask
your fans you can do whatever you want
there's no rule okay but then the most
amount of dick pics will win so I've
taken the liberty of photoshopping each
one of us as a female so we're gonna
start weekend and here's your picture
are you holding a can of Febreze you
know so in case someone doesn't like how
Ken looks like there's more at least
that Ken can offer great cleaning
methods okay I'm gonna go with my
picture next which I didn't do myself a
fan did this one oh god I look like
that's pretty good like you look like a
freaking psycho girl from Silent Hill to
that like to stab you last but not least
and you and you
did this I would brace myself for this
one I'm so ready because I could not
find a [ __ ] picture with you without
the beard okay oh I had to give you some
features that would compensate the beard
oh man I have not changed anything in
the face it's only got the bonus so
we'll see how that goes I'm Mary I'm
very curious how a big cleavage there's
actually there's pictures floating
around of me dressed as a girl anyway
cuz I mean I've done it before you
kidding me I've done it before I guess
it's out there I do that yeah we're
gonna go in there only okay just go okay
Cupid a dating website and we're gonna
create each other's profiles so why
don't you guys go ahead and upload I'll
do hmm we should do each I think you
should do Novus since you gave a
calendar no majestic boobies okay I'll
do Nova so then what am I so sad you can
yeah yeah alright fanfictions right
there my gosh you're gonna have a lot of
people wanting to do you after this
whatever just gonna get mice or more
dick pics alright so can your gonna be
like 60 years old
alright I'm a delicate flower oh damn I
didn't think when I created this my my
username I wrote PewDiePie and they
suggested PewDiePie asaurus okay that's
your name now you live in New York
you're 25 year old woman and you lie you
love to meet strangers with pictures oh
you wouldn't believe it but the username
no hair no problem is tape I was
actually going for that
oh how about that I'm pretty pilots
taking two I'm worried about it all bad
right now you're bisexual female and
you're born around the time of
Valentine's Day okay uh my username be
you matter
this will be public Oh God username send
me your penis password yes please there
we are all right we got it
Oh passwords too weak all right on about
me
how would your best friend describe you
hmm
come on give me give me something good
some people oh no think I'm crazy but
I'm not crazy
this is not gonna give me dig fake I'm
only crazy about love dicks
you have to hide it I'm really good at
giving naughty selfies favorite books
Fifty Shades of Grey hey Ken's picture
actually cropped in pretty good like you
get the four breeze and everything not
so much the toilet that's my best
feature is the toilet fix things I could
never do without my vibrator and my
other five all right so can your about
me is all about your hair okay and this
is indecision just hair on your head so
I put some would say the hair is bad but
I say let us clear the path for hair
hair is the most natural ingredient in
the human body it works well in soup and
just as well in salad burning hair also
creates the utmost erotic aroma
okay you're really good at this I wanna
send dick Oh guys
deep pk7 one visited my profile here oh
my god oh man oh what am I supposed to
be getting a bunch of dudes from from oh
there are really old people that are
coming up for Ken right now all the
desperate ones god damn it I should've
thought about that I mean I think it's
it's it's all for Denver as well like
it's going off of where I bump into
their mess at the market Oh
to people like me things are heating up
oh I need to change your photo cuz your
cleavage is barely showing they're like
big a big a yeah can am I getting any
visitors nope no one loves you actually
you had one when one lady came by to see
what's up this probably has something to
do with my name's to me your penis honey
how do you see like where those visitors
are all here the visitors no one's
visited yet oh can I
nobody has to like so well it sounds
like we're kind of done with the
profiles we're working so hard only I
could get a little too into this yeah
I'm still filling it out here Nova has
three [ __ ] legs really yes I don't
see I don't see any likes boy there's it
says who likes you and I don't have
anybody there yeah well maybe you don't
have a giant [ __ ] cleavage alright
it's gotta be Ken's obsession with hair
that's doing it okay well we're gonna
check in next week to see who got the
best traction or Mo's dick pics
I think chest hair is okay is gonna do
pretty good
I mean he's 62 years old a typical
Friday night if people just watching
Netflix and passing kidney stones okay
it's it sounds like I'm gonna win this
already have to see in the next one